avec nous maintenant le ministre des
finances eric girard bonsoir monsieur
girard bonjour le québec a fait quand
même beaucoup de travail pour arriver à
l'équilibré au fil du temps réduire sa
dette aussi est ce que vous diriez que
l'effort qui a été fait au cours des
dernières années et décennies vient
d'être effacé d'un coup depuis trois
mois
la première chose que je dirais c'est
que l'effort et 15 dernières années
l'issue est cinq dernières années sont
très utiles aux ça lui permet d'absorber
ce qui se passe présentement 2020 21
dans l'année fiscale courant la pandémie
provoquer une récession mondiale
ib mondial ii - trot et demi pour cent
et un choc sur les finances publiques
l'ensemble du gouvernement en note qu un
estimée de 15 milliards
le destine aussi massivement 3
conscience pib c'est gérable et on va
progressivement retourner à l'équilibré
et à la hausse des dépenses donc pas ça
11% pour les portefeuilles cette année
et les revenus autonomes baisse de 9
pour ça c'est des grands écarts la con
qu'on voit jamais habituellement
qu'est-ce-qui récurrents structurelles
danse à la baisse de revenus est en
panne les fonctions de l'interruption
euronor ferme et 40% de l'économie avant
huit semaines et on a dix sont affectés
de façon futurama pok sim hâtivement 10%
d'économies mais ça représente 25 % des
emplois hors de course des as et
tourisme est néanmoins la majorité de la
baisse des revenus est un moral pour ce
qui de la hausse des dépenses
importantes le 6.7 milliards de dollars
la majorité de ces dépenses sont non
récurrents mais
des éléments la baisse des taxes
scolaires salle un effet permanent
l'augmentation des dépenses
d'infrastructures doivent être financées
sur un horizon embêtant et il ya les
hausses limite préposés aux
bénéficiaires que nous entraînons que
nous allons chez par la suite
l'augmentation des effectifs dans le
secteur de la santé bon il est fermé en
même temps on vous sommes confiant je
dirais peut-être même optimiste ans
parce que vous prévoyez pas de hausses
d'impôts il ya des gens qui seront bien
sûr très content de cela vous prévoyez
pas de coupes dans les services publics
mais vous prévoyez le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire d'ici cinq ans
est-ce que cet équilibre repose
essentiellement sur la bonne croissance
de l'économie québécoise sur fusion
éléments d'abord ce que le sujet nous
venons d'aborder savait que la plupart
de la baisse des revenus est temporaire
et que la hausse des dépenses et non
récurrents ensuite la marge de manoeuvre
que nous avions
lee nous étions ans haution de surplus
ou départ au minium pour l'année
précédente s'est donc dit que à long
terme 1 lorsque l'économie reviendra sur
son sentier de long terme à partir de
2002 la base de revenu est plus
importante que la base de dépense au
québec ça ça va nous aider et
notre gouvernement est un gouvernement
qui dédié à augmenter le potentiel de
croissance économique du québec à long
terme donc lorsqu'on va revenir au
sentier d'équilibré nous visons une
croissance de 2%
c'est très important il ya des efforts
importants qui sont faits par le
ministre l'économie de mon côté au
niveau des fils qu'elle utilise
entreprises g en écho me mercier
donc ils ont alloué tendance qu'on va
donner la mise pour le cas de nancy 5-1
au poids donné le sentier comporte
on a hâte de le voir et je comprends
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'incertitudes
mais une des incertitudes c'est de
savoir si les gens vont vraiment
retrouver leur emploi parce que même
vous vous dites décembre 2021 on veut
être revenu au niveau de production
d'avant la pandémie mais le taux de
chômage qui est à 4 4 et demi 5 pour ça
il sera aux 2 7% il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ne seront pas revenus dans leur
emploi en 2021 2022
c'est des revenus en moins pour l'état
ça si l'effectif
le québec vit la pandémie était opéra x
3 avec des grilles productivité et donc
c'est très important
une fusée diot 1 ces personnes à se
replacer avec des investissements en
éducation formation de meilleure
formation en entreprise formation
continue je comprends mais ce que je
vous dis c'est que le chômage restait
relativement élevé pendant un certain
temps encore les revenus ne seront pas
nécessairement la croissance ne sera pas
nécessairement au rendez-vous comme on
le voudrait et vous avez des dépenses
qui vont augmenter avec le
vieillissement de la population et c'est
donc pourquoi vous vous barrer les pieds
en quelque sorte dans un cinq ans en
disant plus je veux pas augmenter les
taxes mes impôts et je veux pas couper
dans les services publics on dirait que
là que le déficit budgétaire le déficit
zéro va revenir presque par magie là
mais en fait c'est là aujourd'hui c'est
un exercice de transparence nous vous
lyon donner l'heure juste aux québécois
sur les coûts de la pandémie si ce que
nous avons fait pour le sentier de
retour à l'équilibré c'est certain qu'on
a besoin de plus d'informations on doit
voir comment voir le décor finement
comment vont les échanges commerciaux
par exemple des données aussi simple que
les taux d'occupation dans l'hôtellerie
cet été on a besoin de toute cette
information
j'ai n'ai jamais dit que ça allait être
facile mais c'est extrêmement important
au but raison d'un point de vue d'équité
intergénérationnelle de revenir à
l'équilibré et ensuite parce que dans
une période d'inflation basse il est
important de ne pas laisser la dette
augmenter de façon trop important parce
que ça va être difficile de contrôler le
poids de la dette si le pib nominal
augmente moins vite
cl s nous prévoyons une période
d'inflation va avoisiner 1 % les deux
prochaines années est important ce
facteur absolument je comprends bien
mais en même temps à 50 % du pib on est
encore sous le poids de 2017
alors on vient pas perdre le contrôle
sur la dette au dessus tout nous avons
indicible de 45% ou 31 mars 2026 ce sera
pas facile d'atteindre 7 c'est bio c'est
à l'automne
on va devoir avoir la discussion on a
deux lois savions de la loi sur
l'équilibré budgétaire qui dit qu'on
doit revenir à l'équilibré et a26 cinq
ans nous avons l'intention de respecter
cette loi est de revenir à l'équilibré
par souci d'équité intergénérationnelle
on a une autre loi sur si on la dette
avec des cibles ans au 31 mars 2010 100
m difficile d'atteindre ses cibles
nous allons avoir une discussion
collective un débat de société autour de
ces cibles à l'otan un débat collectif
sur quoi exactement c'est quoi la
question qu'on va poser aux québécois si
c'est possible d'atteindre les cibles de
la loi sur la gestion de la dette et le
fond les générations est-ce qu'on
pourrait suspendre les versements au
fonds des générations
j'ai eu beaucoup de questions
là dessus aujourd'hui il est pas
question de suspendre les versements au
fonds des générations maintenant nous
continuons c'est un outil qui nous a
aidés par le passé les agences de
notation apprécié cet outil est de toute
façon c'est une discussion qui est un
peu académique et je suis surpris de
l'importance qu'on veut lui donner
aujourd'hui parce que de toute façon la
dette bleue on est des versements au
fonds des générations ou la somme pour
une génération lorsqu on sait qu il veut
lancer la cible la cible de 45 % d'entre
eux n'aura pas obéi b au 31 mars 2006
qui était bon il y a quatre à cinq
milliards de plus en transferts fédéraux
là votre mise à jour par rapport à
l'exercice précédent
est ce que c'est une hausse de 18 pour
salades et rafer fédéraux est ce que ça
fait exceptionnel et oui ces détails un
transfert cette année qui est lié ou aux
travailleurs essentiel il ya une petite
semaine ans en tout début de pandémie
ça c'est entendu l'autre il ya 1,3
milliard et où il n'ya pas entente
fédérale-provinciale présentement
monsieur trudeau en a d'ailleurs parlé
aujourd'hui mais le 5 juin
le gouvernement fédéral a annoncé qu'il
transférait aux provinces 14 millions de
dollars pour la santé et les
municipalités et pas récurrents faux
noms se sont d un transfert non
récurrents et et si même il n'y a pas
d'entente présentement parce que le
québec demandent que ce transport ouah
sans condition et vous ne serez pas
surpris d'apprendre que le fédéral veut
à louise ces sommes à des fonctions et
si mes charges s est pas récurrents dont
c'est un défi budgétaire de plus pour
vous pour revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire mais ça dit que comme cette
année on une provision de 15 milliards
de dollars
on peut dire que c'est laid
le trans l'augmentation discrétionnaire
du transfert sert à construire la haine
a contribué à la progression que nous
avons réservé quatre millions de dollars
pour des mesures de développement
économique ou est nécessaire ou un des
dépenses en santé ou aux du potentiel de
liens merci beaucoup monsieur gérard
pour cet entretien ce soir merci
beaucoup